en el último vídeo de la oscilación de
friedel craft se me olvidó agregar una
molécula que obtenemos en esta reacción
porque tenemos por aquí el anillo vencen
y ccoo con el grupo asilo y el anillo
vencen y ccoo recupera su aroma tizi
that cuando el cloruro de aluminio le da
uno de sus electrones al núcleo del
hidrógeno ok y entonces este electrón se
va con este carbono y así el anillo
vence niko vuelve a tener aro matiz y
that
pero en este proceso también se forma
una molécula de cloruro de hidrógeno
este cloro éste cloro como el otro
electrón de este par de electrones fue a
dar con el núcleo de este hidrógeno
ahora se forma un enlace entre el cloro
y el hidrógeno entonces tenemos por aquí
cloruro de hidrógeno y listo eso es lo
único que nos faltaba